welcome everyone welcome to the today's
webinar the shocking truth about vitamin
D status I'd like to introduce our
speaker today dr. Greg Gregory plotnikov
dr. plotnikov is a board-certified
internist and pediatrician who has
received international honors for his
work in cross-cultural and integrative
medicine gravy is a graduate of Carleton
College Harvard Divinity School and
University of Minnesota Medical School
from 2002 to 2008 dr. Platt MacArthur
there's an associate professor at Yale
University of Medicine where he studied
researched and taught the Campbell
herbal medicine tradition in Japan he
was active in east west medical
integration issues with the Japanese
society of Oriental Medicine National
Geographic and the World Health
Organization he is the recipient of
several international awards for
research and teaching as well as the
early career distinguished Achievement
Award from the University of Minnesota
Medical School dr. plotnikov is well
known for his work in interventional
nutrition herbal medicines and
spirituality and clinical care he has
additional training as a hospital
chaplain in medical acupuncture and my
body skills as a practitioner of
traditional East Asian medicine he is a
co-author of the book trust your gut and
author of 22 textbook chapters and more
than 50 first author articles in medical
literature including several in Japanese
his 2003 article on vitamin D and
chronic pain is one of the most highly
cited articles in the history of mayo
clinic proceedings dr. potna cough
serves as an integrative medicine
position at penny George Institute for
Health and healing and his senior
consultant center of healthcare
innovation allina health care
Minneapolis Minnesota he also serves as
a co-editor of the new journal global
advances and health and medicine please
join me and welcome
dr. great Platte mikov okay well thank
you very much and welcome everyone we're
glad you're here I just want to silence
speakers here we need our IT team to
actually silence the speaker because it
seemed to be ok but I what thank you for
joining me about the shocking truth
about vitamin D status we want to make
this fun we make it we'll make it
practical we want you to enjoy what is
going on and be able to leave today
knowings and things would be important
for your own life and life of the people
you work with and you care about and so
let's go to the first slide here I just
want to acknowledge that i'm not making
off-label use and I do have a financial
relationship to disclose I do have
getting an honorarium for providing this
presentation and what I think guy is
sworn because actually I feel very
passionate about being able to share
this data with you today that will make
a difference home so thank you very much
and we will start with where we are
today it kinds this focus on our lives
around our culture on healthy body
healthy mind healthy spirit and let's go
back to this healthy body what's wrong
with this picture what's wrong with this
picture um I say here we're getting
feedback I'm going to ask you just take
a second out here and I don't have
excuse me everyone is this okay now done
is this okay now done oops that is not
okay so let me just say this is where
I'm working with the issues around
feedback I apologize so everyone healthy
body is kind of a second what's this guy
doing doesn't he know that every photon
touching our skin is a potential
carcinogen and so in fact actually we
live in a culture now were
what used to be the case may know you'll
be the case you may actually be
suffering from a form of nature deficit
disorder and that is we have kind of
creating 24 7 365 feedback in terms of
we are living the same environment every
day and lo and behold front of our
computers is it having a consequence yes
in fact what do we need to be aware of
should we actually be not covering up in
fact can we say well we won't address
that directly but we will say safe
sunning no burning is being very
important but many cultures that world
were actually some has not been a big
part for example Siberia have actually
developed ways of accommodating this and
this is a nice picture from Life
magazine for many years ago and and we
would just have to go and say that in
fact cultures can be very aware of this
I'm getting report that there's still
feedback please let me excuse myself for
a second turn off speakers or other
source I'm sorry done I cannot turn off
speakers here so and we'll just try
moving things so they go on to the next
slide just as ah nothing asked about one
you think our headline like this would
appear ricketts making a comeback in the
UK this something from the 18th century
19th century 20th century that childhood
disease that caused bowed legs and curve
spines making a shocking come back when
would this be reported november eighth
2013 in facts pictures like this are
being increasingly seen worldwide may be
part of your own clinical practice in
fact we actually have kind of ignored
the fact that we may not be all that
progressed beyond Victorian era if in
fact rickets as being so
we seen but we go back to 2010 New York
Times talk about vitamin D what happened
it promised we both talked about and
read about supplement the decade huh why
a huge part of population from robust
newborns to the frail utterly and many
others in between are deficient in this
essential nutrient 2010 New York Times
2010 institute of medicine report on
calcium and vitamin D what's going on
well they lower the definition what
constitutes a normal vitamin D level by
a third to 20 nanograms per ml they
asserted that Americans North Americans
with a few exceptions have sufficient
vitamin D and third they tripled the
recommended vitamin D intake for people
aged 50 or less to 600 international
units per day radical changes and so
what can we say about this well we can
say that that thing's has remained
controversial just last month in The
Lancet a meta-analysis on bone mineral
density suggested that hmm we should not
be giving vitamin D to people seems
inappropriate is what was reported in
The Lancet and yet last week this
article out of a UK newspaper rise in
rickets sparks debate on vitamins for
all under fives in fact actually in the
UK they're debating insisting that all
children get extra vitamin D kind of
contrasting messages here so let's look
at the most authoritative data statement
out of the Institute of Medicine and
that is yes calcium and vitamin D does
play key roles in bone health and yes
they assert that current evidence does
not support other benefits for vitamin D
well this is pretty controversial what
do you mean current evidence
support other benefits welcome some this
evidence idea about what is evidence and
we're going to limit evidence to
randomized control trials and
meta-analyses but make sense of this we
need to cover a little bit about the
biology and pathophysiology of vitamin D
issues so let me just do my review of
what is happening we know that Sun
touching the skin of a certain strength
we're actually kind begin the activation
process of creating pre vitamin D that
then goes to the liver and gets further
and further steps in towards activation
and then many of us been taught goes to
the kidney where it's finally activated
and then to the rest of the body and
this is still true but the nuance is in
fact actually that once at least liver
actually goes to many parts of the body
in fact their vitamin D receptors
throughout the body we're right indeed
will be activated and so can serve as
both an autocrine and a paracrine
function that is local activation local
activity in fact it does not require the
kidney solely to be activated additional
nuances from the latest sciences that
vitamin D receptors throughout the body
that there are p450 enzymes which are
active in both activating vitamin D as
well breaking down vitamin D their
polymorphisms in these and there's great
variability by family by ethnicity etc
and then we have this whole issue of a
vitamin D binding protein and so this is
where the cutting edge of research is at
this time but what do we know for sure
we know that vitamin D is not a vitamin
it's a formal it is a potent seco
steroid of broken steroid that binds the
superfamily nuclear receptors for
steroid hormones including estrogen
testosterone and thyroid and they all
share and they all interact
we do know that a vitamin D receptors
and every tissue of the body cleaning
every brain cell ramune so every muscle
cell and we know that vitamin D is a
regulator of at least a thousand key
genes in the body we also know that
actually there is action non-genomic
responses non-hormonal activity for
vitamin D a variety of things don't need
to know these in specific just to know
that huh there's a lot of biological
plausibility behind activity for vitamin
D not controversial is is the fact that
actually vitamin D regulates
proliferation differentiation apoptosis
so may be relevant to cancer not
controversial that activated vitamin D
plays many roles in key issues with aid
to cancer but what is controversial is
this idea of evidence that doesn't
support other benefits and this is why
it's been so important that we have to
move forward with prospective randomized
control trials because that is the only
contest the only thing I really
constitutes evidence we're throwing a
public health epidemiology we're
throwing out a wick Association studies
biological plausibility they all are
important but do not constitute evidence
according to institute of medicine so
but let's take a look i want you to be
aware of five controversies controversy
number one what is normal and relate
that who is normal and you recognize
that these are profoundly political
questions so let's take a look at how
this applies back in the 70s when quote
normal standards were being addressed
and measurements were first being done
people took a look at two populations
office workers and lifeguards and took a
number of hours in the Sun and water
vitamin D levels and lo and behold those
people who are out the Sun had about
tune of times greater vitamin D status
than those people who quote normal
now which population would you take as
your reference population well people
said hey I'm an office worker I'm normal
therefore that's our reference
population rather than looking at
outdoor workers like lifeguards and
farmers but introduces our kind of a
very interesting issue now because if we
take a look at key issues like were 40
weaken farmers or like here in st. Louis
lifeguards or Israeli lifeguards looking
while running around between 60 and 65
for measured levels the Institute of
Medicine um actually was looking at
levels of 20 and other authoritative
bodies such as and open society have
suggested levels of 30 hmm very
different so who is normal what is
normal remains a very interesting
political question the value judgment
controversy number two and that is this
issue of what is sufficiency in terms of
what is your reference your index
disease so we know index diseases are
all things that traditionally been very
short latencies for example diamond and
very very nice inand pellagra you know
vitamin C and scurvy in providing d
rickets rickets has been the index
disease it's very interesting what
happens with this what about
long-latency diseases these are all
short latency very easy to understand
historically but well not long term
consequences of sub optimal levels what
about different metabolic mechanisms
besides calcium homeostasis for example
and vitamin D and for our clinical
observations are we eating things to
actually non nutritional causes rather
than nutritional status itself now the
Institute of Medicine took this on and
said let's take a look at everything and
that's when they came back and said you
know we only have randomized controlled
trial
on bone health that is going to be what
our index will refer to but let's look
his third controversy again around what
is a normal level nor did the general
recommendation for 400 international
units come from it came from one article
published in nineteen forty in JAMA
actually not even a real article is a
review article in at two paragraphs
addressed the issue around vitamin D
intake these were paragraphs related to
white kids in Boston who did not have
rickets they said why don't these kids
have rickets everyone has rickets and
the point was that oh they're taking cod
liver oil oh how much vitamin D and cod
liver oil at all four hundred Air
National units a tablespoon it's a
tablespoon what they're getting yep okay
that is the recommendation and that for
decades was the limit of the science
that couple paragraphs 1940 review
article on rickets it was repeated in a
1963 Pediatrics article and just taken
as a gospel truth ever since so it was
important and when the IOM take it took
a look and updating this recommendation
and so they went from 400 to 600
international units a recommendation for
most people or rose above 70 possibly
808 said controversy number four you
need to know about is this idea that all
you just need 15 minutes of sun but wait
a second is kinda like there are
latitude issues in fact the further
north you go the closer you get to the
North Pole the less Sun you're going to
get so you can tell you that here I mean
about 45 degrees north in Minnesota but
halfway to the North Pole we can really
only make vitamin D and I tell people
between texts day April fifteenth and
labor day September first roughly
speaking but even that has nuances
because if we take a look at this index
of ultraviolet rays reaching the ground
here in Minneapolis we can see the black
line here which follows a nice bell
curve is what would be predicted for
high noon on a cloudless day the blue
lines here are actually actual
measurements so look at this June July
August you can be out having a great
picnic and still not get much exposure
to ultraviolet be necessary for making
vitamin D in fact if you've ever flown
into a town or city you see a kind of
brown haze over the horizon consider
that a vitamin D umbrella it may look
like you're sunny on the ground but in
fact raised reaching the ground may be
quite different and in fact we've been
reports that Ray's reaching the ground
in a sunny city like Hong Kong a
subtropical city closer to much closer
to the equator in fact have gone down by
at least twenty percent over recent
years because small coming in from
Guangzhou and was an eastern China so in
fact even a nice sunny day may not be
enough fifth controversy and we won't
spend significant time honest and that
is that the eye institute medicine
emphasized that with a few exceptions
all North Americans are we seeing enough
vitamin D now ok question is with a few
exceptions who are these exceptions well
one exception is green immigrants and
refugees so recently I am some
colleagues published on nearly 1400
immigrants and refugees passing through
our Air National clinic here in
Minneapolis st. Paul and we took a look
at vitamin D status upon the arrival
into the United States out of these
nearly 1400 more than 800 were deficient
and deficient was following the
Institute
medicine guideline of 20 nanograms per
ml of these 200 more than 200 or
severely deficient there's a vitamin D
level less than 10 nanograms per ml in
fact it origin made a big difference 126
have 155 Ethiopians from East Africa so
dark skin versus about one-third of
those from Russia light skin shocking
was the fact that the deficiency which
was much worse in young people compared
with old people or sued me i should say
those older than 66 shocking so many
people can have low levels and as young
people so okay you say well that's just
a small portion of our population truth
so let's take a look at data from the
national health and nutrition assessment
so right here you may just get this next
slide here we go okay this is data from
the early 90s and that's the black line
and the around 2000 2004 that's the gray
line this was published in the archives
of internal medicine in 2009 it was not
cited by the Institute of Medicine as
being good stripers they reported that
there is a change in technology halfway
through so making this comparisons are a
little bit nuanced however I won't point
out is it as we look at ethnicities even
with the same technologies there's a big
discrepancy between white and black
mexican-american and others significant
discrepancies and so whether you look at
time from comparison over 10 years are
things going down or you take a look at
approximately the same time there are
significant discrepancies so the
question is how many of the health
disparities in our country are due to
actually vitamin D status rather than
say in other social issues
institutionalized racism and the like it
may just be that we have blinders to
importance of vitamin D status well we
take a look at particularly it severely
or profoundly vitamin D deficient people
look at under African Americans nearly
thirty percent recently we found to be
severely are profoundly bugging D
deficient very different than using same
technologies for other populations hmmm
skin color does make a difference for
whatever reason and if we look at actual
meeting the end up in society's
recommendations with 39 grams per ml in
fact just a very small percentage of
african-american population very small
percentage of mexican-americans three
small part percent of other ethnicities
met that in fact only about thirty
percent of the white population not that
and so therefore we talk about a few
exceptions we can say yes our immigrants
and refugees particularly those with
dark skin as well as our native
population people with dark skin but
even among Caucasians is still very few
very small percentage actually meets an
open society recommendations of thirty
nanograms per ml so we decided to take a
look at this issue here in Minnesota I'm
looking at we were able to study 10,000
646 online of employees in the year 2010
now this is very interesting because the
best majority will write these are
highly educated health professionals
mostly nurses doctors found
syst sea mas and the like people who
know something about health working
health system one hundred percent had
insurance health care insurance was not
a barrier and the two years prior to the
Strega released 15 articles in the local
newspaper on vitamin D deficiency
including a very large Sunday front-page
article with the company what other
articles plus an interactive webinar
plus video massive outreach of our own
vitamin D and on these uniquely in this
country these are all tested within a
very narrow time period and that is
between februari and April of 2010 what
can I say about this well we took a look
at why i ôm standards and by endocrine
society standards of what he is
sufficient and can tell you here's the
data so now to ten thousand six hundred
forty six six percent had levels less
than ten among all the health
professionals additional twenty five
percent had levels less than the
Institute of Medicine requirements so in
fact a total of thirty percent did not
meet in sweet medicine requirements and
we took a look at endocrine society with
guidelines it comes down to sixty
percent of employees I said me
additional thirty percent did not meet
it so all together sixty percent were
less than endocrine society standards
now you can save weight and how could
this be health professionals should be
knowing about this and while maybe we
health professionals saying well we know
this intellectually therefore it doesn't
really matter and like diet and exercise
we know it then it doesn't really count
but in fact actually this does count and
republished in the general occupational
environmental medicine a correlation
between vitamin D status
and actual presenteeism issues we
documented people had level greater than
40 it would have saved our health care
of presenteeism expenses for the company
of 23,000 employees we were too saved
over two and half million dollars okay
so what can we say about self-reported
dosing we can see here that four levels
let's say let's start here with 200 to
400 national units these are the levels
you'll be found in traditional prenatal
vitamin or multivitamin in fact you end
up getting very significantly lower
levels and people who are over here
three to four thousand a day so we can
say yes how much we take does make a
difference no it's a little bit complex
slide we wanted to take a look at women
of childbearing age because these are
women that you are considering the
pregnancy therefore planning ahead and
as health professionals we would expect
them to be kind of head of the curve but
in fact even among these women of
childbearing age look at this weather
thirty percent didn't meet the
requirements of at least twenty
nanograms per ml now the N is pretty big
5,600 women of childbearing age now if
we take a look at women who reported
taking prenatal vitamin right here and
we take a look at the different line so
at 29 grams per ml we look to the side
here in fact Wow big percentages so we
looked at BMI and that's what makes this
complicated so if we look at a BMI of
someone with level less than a B my
lesson 30 about seventeen percent did
not meet the requirements despite taking
a prenatal vitamin or multivitamin and
if the BMI is greater than 30 is about
twenty-five percent or below this
recommendation
now the numbers jump significantly if we
make the recommendation 30 nanograms per
ml so bottom line is we can say that Wow
health professionals working a system
knowledgeable highly insured highly
educated taking a multivitamin or
prenatal vitamin no guarantee that will
be sufficient no I won't also better
point out that this difference about BMI
so here we have to be mind below and
above 30 mm so below 30 in the green
above 30 in the blue and looking at
different dosing across all these dosing
ranges notice that there's a big
difference if you've got to be a mind
greater than 30 it is you're gonna have
a significant lower vitamin D status
forgiven dose than for other people know
given the percent of Americans who have
BMI is greater than 30 it's climbing
skyrocketing this is important clinical
consideration and if we take a look at
high dose we can say thats a high dose
of three to four thousand international
units a day is even then we had
significant numbers of people who are
below the requirements of even the
institute of medicine report so my
concern is and why I wanted to share
with you is wow it's who medicine report
seems to be missing some some concerns
that we can really only address by
actually getting serum measurements and
so let's talk about kind of take home
points from these miss Guetta let me say
that truly female health care workers of
childbearing age have a high incidence
of vitamin D deficiency despite even
they're taking a prenatal or
multivitamin
and that a BMI greater than 30 is a
substantially increased risk of some
sufficient vitamin D levels and even if
someone's taking four thousand and
national units a day no elevated levels
of vitamin D so where do we go with all
this well I now want to talk with you
talk around some concerns about next
steps and where we as health
professionals may be going with this and
so one concern is that the environment
is a denser medicine said there's no
evidence that level is higher than 600
Air National you today you're going to
confer benefits to the population in
fact they can say that there's other
health problems associated with this so
idea that more is better which is such a
American concept if a little bit is good
more is better you're playing up on that
but let's take a look at some nuances
around that number one if we look at
bone health issues as a document by
Willett and Bishop Ferrari and other
kind of noted authorities and
researchers and thank optimal bone
density is found in multiple studies at
levels much greater than 20 nano grams
per ml and it's a nice we citations here
I'm even more importantly they've been
over a dozen studies with an end of
greater than 40,000 they demonstrate
that level of 20 is not enough to either
prevent fractures certainly concerned
about that or false but higher levels do
british medical journal archives of
internal medicine we need to at least
take this in and say hmm this is a
nuanced consideration second thing we're
importance at higher doses are not toxic
you know much fear out there is kind of
mmm if I if I could I this is a
fat-soluble vitamin am I going to create
toxicity if I take more than 600
international units a day we can say
that no actually there's a body is
self-correcting mechanism
taxes e reports and literature people
have been taking millions of
international units on kind of a acute
or basis is not a daily intake over time
because in fact p450 enzymes can be up
and down regulated and so there are
homeostatic protection mechanisms in our
body for this no worries toxicity
actually occurred is believing and
greater levels greater than 200
nanograms per ml so getting up to level
40 to 60 even level 110 Makka main issue
we don't recommend it but it seems like
there's some logic that that we should
feel comfortable having levels at least
around upwards of 60 if that's what
outdoor workers would have we can say
that that's probably not going to be
harmful because we've had many of 10,000
generations of people out in the Sun and
over time so let's take a look at other
laboratory guides which provide nuance
and understanding a normal vitamin D
level if we look at parathyroid hormone
and we plotted against vitamin D
concentrations we see that there's a
significant flexion point at around 20
and that pth plateaus is minimized at
level around 40 if we look at calcium
absorption we know that's optimized at
levels greater than 32 so if we take an
IOM level of 20 and raise that in a
person to 30 and the endocrine society
recommendation calcium absorption
increases by as much as sixty-five
percent of course that that is going to
change in our calcium recommendations a
thousand to 1500 milligrams a day and
that's why the World Health Organization
is said for vitamin D between women 500
milligrams a day is on is recommended
know if people are taking an extra
calcium where is that going they're
going to the
bones we can say no at best extra
calcium has been shown to be just
slightly better than placebo and
increasing bone mineral density it
certainly slows the rate of ross but in
fact um we do have to worry about
calcium deposition elsewhere in the body
so in fact we might not want big intakes
a calcium and there's report in JAMA
just a couple months ago in fact big
intakes of calcium in men appears being
associated increased mortality so again
caution around work this is no we also
have to recognize that if there's a
significant issue around what
constitutes the role of a public health
approach versus a role of a clinical
approach institute of medicine was
acting under a public health
recommendation so this is where a
denominator dispute came to be so they
explain much of the strength of the
Entune medicines recommendations came
from one study of 675 cadavers in
germany and these were people mostly in
accidents if i could almost entirely
accidents so they didn't have any kind
of acute illness they took a look at
remedy status at the time of death and
bone mineral density status at the time
of death and plotted the two against
each other now what is listed here is a
denominator dispute is that the
institute of medicine was making
recommendations for entire population
and so a lot of people have said wait a
second what about these people here who
fall in the category of quote weak bones
and yet we're above the twenty nanograms
per ml recommendation by the I'm why did
I am choose this level as opposed to say
over here main point is
is that they weren't trying to get
everyone taken care of and therefore
these seven people here were under a
denominator of 675 rather than seven out
of 30 in this and so this you can see
wow this is important nuance it is a
value judgment as to what you consider
your denominator is it the whole 675 or
is it seven out of the 30 now from a
clinical perspective most people say hey
I care about these seven people why not
just move the vitamin D requirements up
to 30 and you can say well this is where
public health and clinicians clash and
so you might also say but wait a second
the vitamin D level can change
throughout a year but mineral density
doesn't go up and down much is this a
stock and flow issue in fact was this
really the right study to base
everything on for the institute of
medicine report again i leave that to
you to consider is Pierce be a value
judgment as to whether this is actually
the best guide and clearly there's a
value judgment as to what you can save
your denominator 675 on 3 or 4 700 675
not a big issue or is it 37 out of 30
it's clear that the iom said okay for
population we want this line right here
20 nanograms per ml the author of this
paper just presumed it would be 30
nanograms per ml because the because of
these seven people over here so how does
it I own explain this they say look we
have a public health focus not a
clinical focus we are not making
clinical recommendations we're dressing
free-living non monitored people out and
population so the dietary
recommendations directory recommended
intake and relevant probability
distributions of risk is the focus these
are calculations I'm not based on
particular clinical measurements so what
are the meeting requirements and the
risk and focus on distribution of dose
response effects so it's important
nuance the goal for reporting groups
like the iom is to determine the level
which fifty percent of populations needs
are met the estimated requirement and
the level which 97.5 percent of
population are going to have their needs
met that's the recommended daily
allotment it's been very different than
a clinical perspective we have one
person or one group in front of you and
you want to have a hundred percent
coverage so this is what they had to say
this approach may be disconcerting to
those with a clinical orientation who
are familiar with the medical model and
what's your goal is to treat the patient
in the most efficacious manner to
enhance a positive outcome so in fact
actually this is going to be one thing
we'd have to say ah clinically if I have
a symptomatic person at high risk will
go forward okay so that's why they said
you know k20 appears to have coverage
for the population and this is where we
want to conclude now talking about
challenges going ahead number one dose
versus serum level dose interventions
are based upon a pharmaceutical approach
one size fits all but in fact serum
level is really what matters for
research the best research in the future
we based on serum levels and that is if
we do a pharmaceutical invention the
starting base for everyone is about 04
like a calcium channel blocker so
therefore we can dose but the starting
base for vitamin D status is going
all over the map so one size does not
fit all BM eyes can make a difference
certainly and thus it p450 enzymes are
gonna make a difference etc etc for
vitamin D interventions any
interventional nutrition we need to have
a baseline serum level and a final serum
level second we need to recognize that
there's a difference between a
replenishment goes and a maintenance
dose and will be guidelines they believe
coming out for that third one take a
look at whether her go calcifer or
vitamin d2 which is a very short
half-life versus cholecalciferol d3
which has a longer half-life versus
actual use of activated vitamin D
calcitriol have state load multiple
confounders integrase and heritage and a
jet cetera and then we have to take a
look at issues such as vitamin D
receptor at seaport p450s and the
vitamin d binding protein these are all
things we need going forward I'm a geeky
internist I like numbers measurement
makes a difference for me I cannot just
give one dose for one it doesn't make
any scientific sense so take home point
i would say blood testing is it isn't
very important from a clinical
perspective goals at least the level of
32 I believe clinically is based on on
multiple studies and endocrine society
guidelines in 2011 we can only achieve
that by supplementing in places like
Minnesota in places that are north of
safe 25 degrees above the equator or
below the equator you know multiple
medications were to make a difference
including printed zone and pro kassadin
as well as st. John's wort and the
protease inhibitors and the like and
that their main confounders skin color
tobacco smoke exposure use of sunscreen
working long hours indoors these are all
play a role no I understand we've got
some questions and so let's
open up for questions I believe that
participants you can can type in some
questions and we'll take them from there
and look forward to so my line some
provocative I hope I've been provocative
and so look forward to a QA here so let
me go to word to our Q&A okay so
question coming from gene my parents
both in their 70s and living in Florida
take fifty thousand international units
of vitamin D tube daily okay so this is
earl Calcifer all from mushroom source
should be taking this much and should be
taking vitamin d3 instead so my response
with clinical response number one is I
don't believe anyone needs fifty
thousand international units daily
whether it's be two or d3 this is
someone who I definitely would say we
need a vitamin D level on and if in fact
there are poor levels or low levels we
need to address issues and malabsorption
so it's are unrecognized adverse food
reactivity like such as gluten as a
unrecognized pancreatic exocrine
insufficiency other variety of other
issues but no one needs to be taking
that much every day in fact if I played
hooky today and flew down to florida to
join your parents and spent the day at
the beach i can make about twenty
thousand international units 50,000 is
just beyond anything physiological so it
doesn't make sense question is about st.
john's wort lowering or raising level it
lowers the level st. john's wort is an
anti vitamin d agent NH NIH studies
currently underway that will settle some
of these issues no how about that for a
provocative response the big vital study
we're taking two thousand or natural
units per day
only a small fraction if any are
claiming vitamin D levels measured and
that and it's going to five-year study
for that study be successful there
cannot be any positive reports in the
literature about vitamin D that would
encourage people to go out and do
Diamond D on their own and because it's
placebo controlled or there's a very
limited amount of vitamin D allowed in
in the arm without the 2,000 you
necessary intervention additionally
there the key issues about we know about
absorption and the like I think it's
very very hard to get any practical
clinical data from the vital study and
that's just my opinion I hope to be
proven wrong there's this 20 million
dollars the NIH has just committed 40
million dollars to a good intervention
trial around issues of diabetes and will
be I believe 20 center of the United
States looking that I think it's gonna
be a good trial as long as they're
getting vitamin D levels at the start
and the finish it's kind of
interventional nutrition is not a
pharmaceutical trial we have to know I
know what the baseline and the ending
levels are other any forms our official
light that would do the job as well as
as a son in increasing vitamin D well in
fact actually in vitamin D tanning
booths do exist if he were getting
ultraviolet B and only ultraviolet B can
make vitamin D then people can make
vitamin D in the tanning booth this can
be an issue in fact we kind of showed a
tanning booth at the start from soviet
russia where the kids sitting standing
around their underwear around the green
light we're getting out ultraviolet B
for making vitamin D so for people with
really poor absorption a short bowel
syndrome or other kind of challenges my
recommendation is sometimes to use an
ultraviolet B tanning booth bite
tell people tall over the face and safe
sunning or safe tanning no burning and
this is only used in people who cannot
absorb very well and usually recommend
about the third of the recommended time
for a tam so what are the updated
calcium recommendations for us to
opeenion osteoporosis actually refer you
to the IOM report as I invites me to
step out and make share things from
opinion and bias world health
organization does recommend 500
milligrams of calcium a day for vitamin
D with lead women there is a range of
vitamin D levels includes a high end of
50 men may well take a look at this
question here okay so this is from Susie
and Connecticut there's a range of
desired vitamin D levels include high
end of 50 main websites talk about
patients near amp up to 80 is a research
of X of a limit of 50 know at this time
there's very little guidance around what
is an optimal vitamin D level so anyone
who's making recommendation beyond the
endocrine society recommendations are
greater than 30 it's really drawing more
inference and then we don't have solid
research to support levels granite
hating a lot of people looking
epidemiologic studies and saying oh well
lifeguards run levels around 60 maybe
that's where we should be yes that's why
there are suggestions by the endocrine
society that a level 40 to 60 nanograms
FML might be ideal but we don't have
definitive and data to support that okay
so related to this is I'm on know right
I'm still unclear if maintaining a level
of 75 to 100 nanograms per ml and that's
roughly roughly 30 to 40
now go save 75 to 100 nanograms per ml
is ideal or sister the high end of the
spectrum that's in high end of the
spectrum we do not have good data to
suggest that and so and so a best that
is for you to work in partnership with
your health professional on does
prednisone affect vitamin D level yes in
fact actually decadron even more so data
just presented the Society of
integrative oncology last month from
researchers in Vancouver a prostate
health center demonstrated definitively
that decadron has profoundly altered
vitamin d metabolism and results in
significantly lower levels of serum
vitamin D same thing prednisone effects
of vitamin D functioning at the quartus
at the cellular level and so we have
four people on prednisone or make sure
that they're already at risk for bone
loss making sure they have good vitamin
D levels so it sun exposure more than
some or sufficiently vitamin d
supplementation and tropical areas yeah
so we can do just fine in tropical areas
as long as we're outside in the Sun not
working long hours and doors safe
sunning no burning okay Miriam reports
that i use have moods ups and downs and
began taking four thousand daily since
then they've really felt improvement
what do you think about the role vitamin
d and belly remedy polymorphisms and
depression fascinating research out
there around the role vitamin d and mood
and i would urge everyone who is
interest in this topic to just go to
pubmed and put in vitamin d and
depression you'll be kind of stunned
what were what is being reported however
most of these reports are associations
your have not been intervention trials
all we have is anecdotes like your
report Miriam without doing much better
and that's includes like major
depression includes seasonal affective
disorder and alike vitamin D
as a hormone appears be as important as
our other hormones thyroid estrogen
testosterone if we're low on them we
have time systemic effects and so my
point is why if someone is symptomatic
let's make sure that lessor vitamin D
levels are good daily versus monthly
dosing is an important topic thank you
young bin for writing on this i
recommend daily because monthly you're
going to get here you've got
pharmacokinetics you've got too much
variation you cannot guarantee a good
normal level throughout the month with a
single dose because you activate your
sip p450s to to actually break down the
vitamin d very quickly so a steady
gentle dose daily makes more sense so
you go there's live energy behind
promoting vitamin D as part of
preventing breast cancer has anything
changed in this topic well in fact a
society for integrative oncology were
becoming a report on breast cancer
recommendations in very near future
again pubmed who has a huge literature
and vitamin d in breast cancer risk we
do know that vitamin d is a hormone that
does regulate cellular proliferation
differentiation apoptosis and plays a
synergistic effect with gamma radiation
and multiple chemotherapeutic agents
according to the literature has not been
subjected to large randomized
prospective trials so quote evidence
does not exist but again for anyone with
a history of cancer my point is given
that there's so much deficiency in this
country why not guarantee that there's a
sufficiency during a major health
challenge but we'd only know that
bhayecha gang measurements and so I've
been shocked by a number of patients
I've seen with cancer diagnosis with
high risk factors by now absorptions
like paint grata cancer patients like
we've never had a vitamin D
checked even though gemcitabine and
vitamin D have a nice synergistic effect
so we need to increase the awareness
that actually this is a confounder for
clinical trials I certainly hope they're
the grameen no false negative clinical
trials of a promising chemotherapeutic
agent because the population had a
little vitamin D level we certainly saw
that with interferon and hepatitis C is
that the disproportionate effect of
interferon ribavirin therapy peptide see
was based on fact that actually
african-americans the population had low
vitamin D levels and the actual
mechanism of action of the therapeutic
intervention depended on the vitamin D
level same thing can occur in cancer I
believe as well more data needed do in
vitamin D levels of sucks effect sleep
patterns Thank You Carmen for writing
about this I noticed that being after
being vitamin D depleted after many
years living in Norway I took 5,000
nationals a day and had very vivid
dreams and slept very well and he's been
couple articles in the medical
literature suggesting that vitamin D
deficiency is a contributor to sleep
disruption we certainly know that
vitamin D receptors throughout the brain
including areas related to mood and
sleep and so it makes sense that if one
is depleted and living in Norway
certainly a risk factor then then
replenishment would have a difference
this has not been subjected to
randomized control trials so again we
need to have more measurements and more
intervention trials in the literature to
say with definitively but this reason is
kind of a question for the larger group
though and that is the question about
well for something which is low cost and
low toxicity easily measured and
monitored why not and here's here's bias
and opinion my biased opinion is that
vitamin d represents a single most cost
effective medical intervention we have
in North America today single most cost
effective medical intervention we have
why aren't we putting it into play again
it's a value judgment accumulate right
some people get little sunshine such as
those in the northwest seattle portland
and the like typically have winter
depression and seasonal affective issues
does taking vitamin d someone's help to
increase these bouts with depression
multiple anecdotal reports say yes this
is an icing for n of 1 clinical trials
with your health professional consider
actually you know gang and measurement
replenishing normalizing doesn't make a
difference now obviously seasonal
affective depression wasp affected by
exercise and by circadian rhythm
management and so the use of
phototherapy light boxes and melatonin
may also be playing a significant role
but if I Mindy I again these false
negative in trials I would not want
there to be a phototherapy lightbox
trial for a circadian rhythm management
without a normal vitamin D level it
could be a confounder even have a false
negative trial hazard been an increase
in osteomalacia as well as rickets thank
you gentlemen for writing this in fact
actually new UK report in last 15 years
the incidence of rickets has gone up
fourfold that has kids with severe
enough wickets to be hospitalized has
gone up fourfold in last 15 years in the
UK if we move on osteomalacia think
about the chronic pain populations the
United States you know the article that
I publishing in the mayo clinic
proceedings in 2003 went on to become
when most highly cited articles the
history of the journal showing that
people with chronic nonspecific
musculoskeletal pain had extremely low
vitamin D levels is that part of the
clinical practice no I for anyone with
chronic pain brevet catching a lot of
nonspecific chronic musculoskeletal pain
really is an osteomalacia syndrome and
so again before putting someone on
oxycodone or doing a lot of intervention
trials which are expensive
such as injections and the like or
certainly surgery I would want to make
sure that people are getting at least
normal vitamin D levels in the 2003
report I document five people with
unmeasurable vitamin D levels including
one gentleman who went from multiple
back surgeries and angioplasties with no
demonstrable disease but then well this
may be distal lesion and this art and
coronary artery and keeps coming to the
emergency room let's go an angioplasty
in over two hundred thousand dollars
worth of interventions before this ago
we had no vitamin D huh so I'm thinking
that anyone with a chronic pain
condition is not well explained before
doing big expensive intervention so
let's at least make sure they've got
good vitamin D level do you think some
of those benefits of sun exposure are
due to cholesterol sulphate synthesis
rather than vitamin D well thank you
catherine for writing about this it's
very interesting that our pre vitamin d
is a 70 hydro cholesterol so the
question is why do cholesterol levels go
down in the summer for populations and
up in the winter as have anything to do
with vitamin D exposure interesting
hypothesis what does it mean to be on a
stem does that block 7 be hydro
cholesterol production and therefore
reduce our capacity to make vitamin D
from the Sun interesting hypotheses kind
of strange new science but hold that
question we need data on this these are
great hypotheses that need to be tested
we talked about connection between
vitamin D and chronic pain and chronic
low back pain in the medical literature
there are a lot of studies on vitamin D
and chronic low back pain one that is a
practical clinical on consideration was
published in spine in 2002 or 2003
looking at 650 people coming to a
surgical low back pain clinic in Saudi
Arabia they found that these people all
were profile
vitamin D deficient and after replacing
the vitamin D I just a handful needed
back surgery dr. Schellenberg in Canada
published on six people with severe low
back pain awaiting surgery in the
Canadian National Health Service in fact
found that just replenishing the vitamin
D they do not need to go to surgery so I
think that these are very provocative
things there is a literature out there
but there are more small reports they're
not high quality evidence by evidence
hierarchy so they still represent
important hypotheses that would be need
to be tested my question is given the
paucity of research funding why not do a
trial right here right now on your own
patient get a level replenish it
remeasure and assess pain status and
functionality repaint inventory fatigue
inventories promised ten or twenty nine
there's lots of validated instruments
that will help you document for your
patient did this make a difference and I
think that it would make sense for
health systems to say look before you go
for a hundred-thousand-dollar back
surgery or spinal fusion or other things
let's at least make sure your vitamin D
level is normal and see how well you do
with that thank you for writing dinara
from Moscow dobroe utro spasiba there is
an idea from some dietary specialist
said that there should be a better split
and in taking two portions say twice per
day I don't have a good understanding of
the data to support that because this is
a fat-soluble vitamin and and so levels
don't bounce a lot around dosing and so
and so they do not bounce signaling day
to day such as a like other environments
such as B vitamins which are
water-soluble
we'll have significant variation if
there's additional gather that love to
see it and then I'll let people know
that please contact me here's my email
address with questions Gregory plotnikov
at allina al Li Na com or through a
website Gregory plotnikov com or through
website trust your gut calm the book on
God distress will continue taking
questions for a couple minutes here what
daily dose and i recommend i say dose
does not matter what counts as serum
level there is no one dose that fits all
so i cannot make recommendations i can
tell you some people require six hundred
a day some people require six thousand a
day i do know from randomized trials
published by funded by the NIH and
published by hollis and wagner and
demonstrated that for breastfeeding
mothers you need at least four thousand
international units a day to get good
breast milk vitamin d levels for your
infant so that would be one thing i can
say for sure there's data guiding that
and our clinical trials and say done at
allina and in partnership with mef
general we can say that many people
require significantly greater levels
than 600 international units a day if
they're especially if they're vitamin D
deficient to begin with but we can only
know by measuring I can't tell someone's
cholesterol level by looking at them I
can't tell their thyroid functioning
very much by looking at them I can't
tell their INR by looking at them I
can't tell the digoxin level develop Oh
Cass level we get measurements that is
what guides us it makes the invisible
visible and that's very important for
for vitamin D status common writes about
link between vitamin d ms and ra
and we certainly know that the further
north you go the higher the incidence of
MS and now even RA has recently been
published as well and these are local
are the recent data on the are a
long-standing data from the US
Department defense and others around
multiple sclerosis people said huh maybe
it's a vitamin D dependent issue because
vitamin D in latitudes see me so closely
correlated the definitive studies have
not been published however anyone at
risk for these again there are multiple
other reasons but really just focusing
just on bone health we'd want to
normalize the vitamin D level but we do
not vitamin D is a potent regulator the
immune system and that is the that is
well defined by the literature and so we
know that there is a biological
plausibility the vitamin D then would
have something to do with things related
to the immune system so biological
plausibility hypotheses that vitamin D
status can play a role in autoimmune
disease can play a role and infectious
disease and if we look at data from the
VA hospitals around total cost of care
around infectious disease issues we know
that vitamin D status plays a big role
we look at data presented at the in
society north american society of
critical care i'm sorry i'm not citing
the right society here but we know that
there in abstracts presented about
vitamin d status and morbidity and
mortality and ICU units recent nice
article and pediatric ICU units and
medical literature again this is
peer-reviewed medical literature
associations you're not intervention
trials and so but the valuable sociation
is it may not be good evidence but
certainly is a good hypothesis and while
we wait for randomized control trials
and significant funding to generate
those
we can always do this in our patients
ourselves n of 1 trials is my patient
efficient and if I replenish that
doesn't make a clinical difference so
this is a question important question
from Millie what's the difference
between a 125 dihydroxy vitamin D and a
25-hydroxyvitamin d serum levels is the
measuring in 125 useful and and so the
the question here is 25-hydroxyvitamin d
levels are the best measures of vitamin
D status period we measure 125 only in
very special situations such as
sarcoidosis for example where you can
actually have high 125 levels being
produced as a calcic trial I imagine
also if we're doing calcitriol
interventions that we also want to
measure that as well to make sure that
we're not producing moving towards a
hypocalcemic state so for vast vast vast
vast majority of clinical situations the
25 at this time is the best measure now
there's research going on take a look at
additional value for 125 nothing to
report solidly on that at this time okay
but indeed connection with neurologic
psychologic disorders thank you know for
writing about this very interesting
study taking a look and just published
on taking a look at vitamin D status and
determinants of metabolic syndrome and
other factors associated with morbidity
and mortality in serious mentally ill
patients and in fact it appears that
vitamin D intervention does make a
difference at least in one trial you
might concern about mental health is
that it's the measureless medicine is
based on listening
mostly two people at a deep soul level
and making decisions based on intuitive
sense as an internist I like quantifying
and so in fact there's great
opportunities now from mental health and
primary care and other physicians to
partner together and to bring on the
best of intuitive qualitative subjective
understanding and the best of
quantitative understanding and because
vitamin D is low cost low toxicity
toxicity intervention gagan vitamin D
level in it seems be well supported in
the medical literature as a reasonable
clinical assessment to understand the
status of the patient um can vitamin D
it be Keith who died alone Robert thank
you for asking this question there is
like no vitamin D in the diet sorry it
was a kind of you know unless you're
eating like a entire Sam in the day or
doing a couple gallons of milk a day
you're not going to get a lot of vitamin
D in the diet particularly northern
climates yes there's 10 international
units of vitamin D in an egg well if
you're needing minimum you know your
nudes 60 eggs a day I don't think so so
um so the USDA has reported at least in
the past at twenty-eight percent of all
skim milk samples that had vitamin D
listed on the label head to vitamin D in
the product itself so you're not going
be guaranteed getting good vitamin D
intake drinking a gallon or more of milk
a day and most of I know I can't say
name a single gulp who needs to be
taking in significant amounts of cow's
milk fortified cows mullen so for this
reason that's why I say you know safe
sunning no burning in the months we can
make vitamin D for free but if you work
long hours indoors like most people
watching this and listening to this now
you can need to supplement and guidance
for supplementation requires measurement
but at least at 45 degrees north we need
to supplement at least in
september-october November December
January covering March and April it's
just a few months we can do it but if
you have a great July fourth picnic and
get a good vitamin D dose from being
outside and jen with that by the deal we
gone by Labor Day and if you have a
great labor day picnic get good but
indeed dose that vitamin D generally be
gone by Halloween so to you no guarantee
good vibe indeed levels and northern
hemisphere in january-february March and
April absolutely requires either someone
to write your prescription for a week in
South America or Hawaii or Florida on a
beach or to supplement and
supplementation does not need to be
expensive vitamin D is the same as
vitamin d3 and so all the stores carry
it and now I even saw at a gas station
the other day so it's widely available
the more demand you create for vitamin D
supplements aren't you going to push the
cost up and well actually have not seen
that vitamin D should not be expensive
this cheap cheap cheap cheap cheap I
know it one big box retailer nationwide
two thousand international units is
about one point eight cents per day it's
not going to go up significantly it
means that means a good dose for entire
pregnancy would be less than five
dollars okay d 2 versus d3 and d2 comes
from mushrooms d3 comes from sheep when
one if anyone has concerns about animal
products even though it's outside the
animal comes with from a sharing of the
wool then use of d2 to make sense d 2 is
not dose per dose is not the same as G 3
D 2 has a much shorter half-life and so
it's not going to hang around nearly as
much as d3
but for anyone worried about you know
kind of pushing a mint in toxicity as
many of us were 10 15 years ago that's
why he too was so popular now we know
that d3 is not not so much an issue are
not seeing toxicity should children's
vitamin D levels be different from
adults well actually thank you Susie for
asking about this actually um it's
really his levels compared to be the
same for everyone and in terms of
requirements has not been well straight
and children I think we're going to see
more data on that in the future but in
the breast feeding trials we're looking
at achieving same vitamin D levels as we
would for older children adolescents and
adults ok um is it went between low
vitamin D mastiha prosess yet absolutely
you know Jenna thank you for writing but
absolutely no criminal question people
who demonstrate lo buying the D level do
those people also commonly present with
problems such as anemia or celiac
disease yes yes so of your differential
diagnosis around malabsorption issues or
refractory anemia there's a nice article
and reflect on the Nemean children just
published very recently have to consider
vitamin D status and the differential
working at the differential diagnosis
certainly celiac is a malabsorption
issue you're going to have fat
malabsorption consequences with that and
also appears to extend to non-celiac
gluten sensitivity issues and we can
have fat malabsorption issues and so all
fat nutrients need to be considered for
that vitamin D in psoriasis young Ben
thank you for writing about this Michael
Holick professor of medicine and
dermatology at Boston University as she
did a lot of solid research on this and
topical vitamin D is now a commercial
product for treatment of psoriasis
psoriasis being
an issue of cellular proliferation and
differentiation and a pop ptosis means
that vitamin D does regulate those key
genes and we know that environment that
vitamin D interventions and top
conventions as rias's have been shown to
make a difference so a person writes
about possibility of inheritance with
poor vitamin D levels one patient
presents with low vitamin D should the
rest of the family be tested a very
practical question it all depends on the
clinical situation the nuances are BMI
and dose and activity levels and sun
exposure and all these things play a
role in that however I can speak about
my own family it's kind of we tend to
require significant higher levels than
than others and thats related to
ethnicity and and jeans people who come
from the indian subcontinent the India
Pakistan Bangladesh and the like
genetically have very fast by McGee
breakdown enzymes and so therefore it
becomes a big issue moving from Delhi to
London or Minneapolis or Toronto
sniffing issues there may also be true
for people from West Africa East Africa
and the like how should soon should we
start supplementation for babies
prenatally this kind mother vitamin D
status if you type in maternal vitamin D
status and and pregnancy you'll find a
very interesting literature on this if
we look at peer-reviewed articles in
leading pediatric literature including
pediatrics publisher American Academy of
Pediatrics vitamin D status does Peter
play alone all kinds of neural cognitive
issues so prenatally we want to make
sure moms have a normal vitamin D level
throughout pregnancy
and we wanna make sure that the child is
breastfeeding that there's enough
vitamin D in the breast milk and that
means that mother should be taking four
thousand international units a day based
on randomized controlled trials and if a
child is bottle feeding on will make
we're going to calculate total button
the intake by the volume of bottle
feeding d drops are one product there
are liquid vitamin D products available
on the market and so that would be
something to consider easily
administered do you get a good amount of
vitamin D from mushrooms and you can if
they're sun-exposed a happy song suppose
they have to have ultraviolet B exposure
what is the dose it depends upon the
thickness of the skin so I published
data with Paul Stamets where we looked
at shiitake maitake and rice che
mushrooms exposed to the Sun demonstrate
profound increases environment d content
is this though a defining dose no it is
it and so we have to be cautious about
could get too much well I guess it
depends how much are you fighting
mushrooms okay historical note about
one-third about traditional East Asian
herbal medicine formulas use a mushroom
on which in japanese is pronounced blue
creo in Chinese Zhu Ling this is pouria
cocos wolf it was actually dug up out of
the ground in blocks chuck up into
little pieces and dried in the Sun large
surface area sun exposure so by
historical reference we can say that
medicinal mushrooms found in traditional
east asian medicines and she could have
a huge amount of vitamin d and that may
have been part of their therapeutic
effectiveness contemporary traditional
chinese medicine and japanese medicine
creating medicine formulas available
commercially are all dried in
ovens and therefore have no vitamin D in
them and so therefore and people
pursuing these healing traditional
approaches may also want to get five
indeed levels measured and supplemented
if appropriate okay going through and
taking a look at additional questions
here okay another question is there any
work done unbalanced between fat soluble
vitamins like a d e and K the reason I
ask it came across some blog posts as a
medical professional post said when they
once that salgo violence should not be
supplemented Brazil pull out other pets
valuable fat soluble stored vitamins
causing deficiency of those so if we
supplement vitamin D with a cause
deficiency of a e or k hmm hmm very
interesting question I cannot answer
that I'm sorry if anyone hasn't has a
data to guide this answer please let me
know I'm curious about that I don't uh I
don't understand that and but is relayed
to a question Miriam has about is a
normal vitamin D level does that mean a
normal level and other tissues and we
believe that the distribution is equal
throughout the body what is not equal is
local activation and that is the one
alpha hi the 125 alpha hydroxylase for
activating producing kelso trial is
actually varies and so that's why they
talk about paracrine and autocrine
addition to
endocrine functioning of vitamin D is
that you can have local environments
that could be so it could be locally
regulated responses and so therefore we
won I believe in making sure that
upstream levels are normal and giving
the body allowing the body of the wisdom
to do what it needs to do with it and
which we don't have a very deep
understanding of local regulation and
its relationship to serum level at least
edit clinical along a basic science
level we're learning a lot we don't know
what that means in ain't given human
being at this time and so I think if we
wrap up here I'm going over I appreciate
you're paying attention here but please
feel free to contact me and Gregory
plotnikov com or Gregory plotnikov at
allina calm AOL IM a happy to be helped
my goal in life is to be helpful i try
to speak from data and i try to be aware
of i'm speaking from opinion and bias
and try to i'll try to identify what I'm
doing from either i hope this has been
provocative and interesting and
appreciate your time and attention thank
you all very much